OK, so I want to tell you a story, and I'm going to start with the part you probably already know about. In November, six Democrats, all veterans of the US military or intelligence communities, came out with a video, saying to people in uniform, you took an oath like we did.
好的，我想给你们讲个故事，我就从你们可能已经知道的部分开始讲起。去年十一月，六位民主党人，他们全都是美国军队或情报界的退伍军人，发布了一段视频，对穿军装的人说，你们和我们一样宣过誓。
Our laws are clear. You can refuse illegal orders.
我们的法律很明确。你们可以拒绝非法命令。
You can refuse illegal orders.
你们可以拒绝非法命令。
You must refuse illegal orders.
你们必须拒绝非法命令。
No one has--
没有人有——
Those are Senators Mark Kelly and Elissa Slotkin and Congressman Chris Deluzio. They did not specify what illegal orders they might be referring to. At the time, just like now, the Trump administration was shooting boats of supposed drug runners out of the water off the coast of Venezuela, and lots of military experts and veterans were saying this did not seem to be legal. In the past, if we found boats of drug runners, we arrested them. We didn't just kill them on the spot in cold blood with no due process.
那是参议员马克·凯利 (Mark Kelly) 和埃丽莎·斯洛特金 (Elissa Slotkin) 以及国会议员克里斯·德卢齐奥 (Chris Deluzio)。他们没有具体说明他们所指的非法命令是什么。当时，就像现在一样，特朗普政府正在委内瑞拉海岸外击沉所谓的毒贩船只，许多军事专家和退伍军人都说这似乎并不合法。过去，如果我们发现毒贩船只，我们会逮捕他们。我们不会仅仅因为没经过正当程序，就在现场冷血地杀掉他们。
The video also didn't mention the president trying to order the National Guard into American cities, Portland and Chicago, where judges stopped the orders, saying they were illegal. Like I say, the video mentioned no specific orders at all.
视频也没有提到总统试图下令国民警卫队进入美国城市，如波特兰和芝加哥，法官们阻止了这些命令，称其为非法。就像我说的，视频根本没有提到任何具体的命令。
And really, the video might have vanished into the daily noise of a million news stories and online videos, like almost everything else does these days. It really could have come and gone and been forgotten, except that the president went on Truth Social and called the video seditious behavior, punishable by death. He said he wanted the lawmakers to be tried as traitors. Stephen Miller, who seems to run so many things in the White House these days, went on TV to declare--
说实话，这段视频本可能像如今几乎所有其他东西一样，消失在成百上千条新闻故事和网络视频的日常噪音中。它确实可能来去匆匆，被人们遗忘，但总统在“真实社交”(Truth Social) 上称这段视频为煽动性行为，可判处死刑。他说他希望这些立法者以叛国罪受审。斯蒂芬·米勒 (Stephen Miller)，这位如今似乎在白宫掌管着许多事务的人，在电视上宣称——
It is insurrection, plainly, directly, without question. It's a general call for rebellion, saying that those who carry weapons in America's name should defy their chain of command and engage in open acts of insurrection.
这显然、直接且毫无疑问是叛乱。这是一种公开的叛乱号召，声称那些以美国名义携带武器的人应该反抗他们的指挥链，并参与公开的叛乱行为。
So in other words, we ended up in one of those completely exhausting and very familiar standoffs between Republicans and Democrats, with the Democrats saying, we're just telling people to obey the law, and Republicans saying the Democrats, as always, are trying to overthrow Trump, this time with a military insurrection. And in the middle of all that are the two million people serving in the active military or National Guard or Reserves right now.
换句话说，我们最终陷入了共和党人和民主党人之间那种极其令人疲惫且非常熟悉的对峙中，民主党人说，我们只是在告诉人们要遵守法律，而共和党人则说，民主党人一如既往地试图推翻特朗普，这一次是用军事叛乱。而在这一切的中间，是现在在现役军队、国民警卫队或预备役中服役的二百万人。
What are they thinking? Are many of them worried about getting illegal orders or getting legal orders that they're not comfortable with? We reached out to the handful of organizations that service people can call if they want confidential legal advice on that kind of thing. None of them could put us in touch quickly with any of the service people they talked to, but they all did confirm that they've seen an uptick in calls since the Trump administration came in. Most did not see more calls after the Democrats' video.
他们在想什么？他们中有许多人担心会收到非法命令，或者收到让他们感到不安的合法命令吗？我们联系了一些组织，军人如果想就此类事情寻求保密法律咨询，可以致电这些组织。他们都没有让我们很快联系到他们交谈过的军人，但他们都证实，自特朗普政府上台以来，打来电话的次数有所增加。大多数人表示在民主党发布视频后，电话并没有变多。
And I want to emphasize the numbers of calls that they get are low compared to the immense size of the Armed Forces. GI Rights Hotline has been getting a little over 200 calls a month, on average, since June. An organization called About Face only gets a few calls a week. Brittany Ramos DeBarros answers all those calls. She's an Army vet who served in Afghanistan.
我想强调的是，与庞大的武装部队规模相比，他们接到的电话数量很少。自六月以来，“GI权利热线”(GI Rights Hotline) 平均每月接到两百多个电话。一个叫“About Face”的组织每周只接到几个电话。布列塔尼·拉莫斯·德巴罗斯 (Brittany Ramos DeBarros) 负责接听所有这些电话。她是阿富汗退伍军人。
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
The Pentagon wants to create these quick response forces, 500 National Guard in each state, to control civil unrest and riots. Have you heard about that?
五角大楼想要建立这些快速反应部队，即每个州各五百名国民警卫队员，来控制内乱和骚乱。你听说过吗？
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
Earlier in the year, most of her calls were from the National Guard. Then, that changed in June.
今年早些时候，她接到的大多数电话来自国民警卫队。然后，到了六月，情况发生了变化。
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
Have you heard from people who've refused orders already?
你是否已经接到过拒绝执行命令的人打来的电话？
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
And what were the orders? What kind of orders?
那些是什么命令？是什么样的命令？
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
Right.
没错。
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
Because of her hotline's confidentiality rules, I should say we could not confirm this story or the others that she told us by talking to the service people involved. But we were able to verify many details.
由于她热线的保密规则，我应该说明，我们无法通过与相关军人交谈来证实这个故事或她告诉我们的其他故事。但我们确实能够核实许多细节。
Brittany says she does not advise anybody on what they should do, but tells them what their options are. People can stay in their units and speak out publicly about things that they object to, within certain limits. But even if they follow the rules, they could face all kinds of consequences.
布列塔尼说她不建议任何人应该做什么，而是告诉他们有什么选择。人们可以留在自己的部队中，并在一定限度内公开说出他们反对的事情。但即使他们遵守规则，也可能面临各种后果。
People who want out can file papers to be conscientious objectors, which can lead to wildly various outcomes. They can be reassigned to other duties, or they can be discharged. Simply refusing to obey orders can get you court martialed. Of course, people can choose to do nothing.
想要退出的人可以提交文件成为良心拒服兵役者，这可能导致截然不同的结果。他们可以被重新分配到其他职责，或者被开除。仅仅拒绝服从命令就可能让你被送上军事法庭。当然，人们可以选择什么都不做。
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
Can you think of somebody like that and tell me about that conversation?
你能想到这样的人吗？能告诉我关于那次谈话的情况吗？
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
It can be hard to figure out what to do sometimes. I was in Mexico, in Oaxaca, a couple weeks ago. And in this church, in Spanish on one of the walls, it said, here are the remains of people like you and like me, people who knew how to act with faith and charity in the historic moment and the circumstances that God decided to put them in.
有时候很难弄清楚该做什么。几周前，我在墨西哥的瓦哈卡。在教堂里，墙上的一段西班牙语写着：这里安息着像你我一样的人，那些知道如何在上帝决定的历史时刻和环境里，以信仰和仁慈行事的人。
And I read that, and I thought, am I doing the best I should be doing in the historic moment that God decided to put me in?
我读了这段话，心想，在上帝安排我所处的历史时刻，我是否在做我应该做的最好的事情？
Today on our show, history comes knocking, and a bunch of people have to figure out what to do. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天的节目中，历史正在敲门，一群人必须弄清楚该做什么。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这是《美国生活》(This American Life)。我是艾拉·格拉斯 (Ira Glass)。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, Act One, "Mother Knows Best."
这是《美国生活》，第一幕，“母亲最懂”。
Fela Kuti is at a special level of fame where, yes, lots of people have no idea who he is. But for people who do, there could not be a bigger musical star. He was a worldwide musical phenomenon by the 1980s, iconic, from Nigeria. He ushered in an entire new genre of music, which he called afrobeat.
费拉·库蒂 (Fela Kuti) 的名气处于一个特殊的水平，确实，很多人根本不知道他是谁。但对于那些了解他的人来说，没有比他更大的音乐明星了。到 1980 年代，他是享誉全球的音乐现象，是尼日利亚的偶像。他开创了一种全新的音乐流派，他称之为“非洲节拍”(afrobeat)。
Fela was also a profoundly political figure. Nigeria was still a newly independent country in the 1970s and '80s, still very much trying to answer questions about what kind of nation it was going to be. Fela's songs criticized colonialism in all of its forms, openly challenged Nigeria's ruling military government. He took on apartheid South Africa and the United States.
费拉也是一位深刻的政治人物。在 1970 年代和 80 年代，尼日利亚仍是一个刚独立的国家，仍在非常努力地回答它将成为一个什么样的国家的问题。费拉的歌曲批判了各种形式的殖民主义，公开挑战尼日利亚的军政府。他挑战了南非的种族隔离制度和美国。
All dey talk of Black man power
一直在谈论黑人力量
Water, him not get enemy!
水，是没有敌人的！
I dey talk of Black power, I say
我在谈论黑人力量，我说
Water!
水！
Fela called for the complete rejection of most things European and Western and tried to live that way. He went so far as to found his own commune and declared it to be its own republic, free of government control.
费拉呼吁彻底拒绝大多数欧洲和西方的事物，并试图以此方式生活。他甚至建立了属于自己的公社，并宣布它是一个独立的共和国，不受政府控制。
His politics were radical, but also messy. His version of being an Africanist led him to pretty ugly views about gay people and women. They make him a complicated person to explain.
他的政治主张很激进，但也一团糟。他对非洲主义的解读导致了他对同性恋者和女性相当丑陋的看法。这使他成为一个难以解释的复杂人物。
Recently, Jad Abumrad embarked on a journey to do just that. Jad is the creator and longtime co-host of Radiolab, and he did a big series on Dolly Parton that won all kinds of awards and lots of people heard. Now, he's put out a whole series about Fela, and a big chunk of it is about how Fela's music and his politics spoke to each other.
最近，贾德·阿布姆拉德 (Jad Abumrad) 开始了一段旨在做到这一点的旅程。贾德是 Radiolab 的创始人和长期联合主持人，他制作了一个关于多莉·帕顿 (Dolly Parton) 的大型系列节目，赢得了各种奖项，许多人都听过。现在，他推出了一个关于费拉的完整系列节目，其中很大一部分是关于费拉的音乐和他的政治主张如何相互呼应的。
And one of the stories that Jad tells, a story that we're going to excerpt here today, is about where Fela's anti-colonial politics came from. Jad says that some of those beliefs can be traced back to his mother, Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti. The story of her political accomplishments is not that well known outside of Nigeria, and it's kind of an amazing story on its own. What she did in her small town helped transform the entire country. Here's Jad with the story.
贾德讲述的故事之一，也就是我们今天在这里摘录的故事，是关于费拉的反殖民政治思想的来源。贾德说，其中一些信念可以追溯到他的母亲富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂 (Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti)。她在尼日利亚以外的政治成就并不为人所知，这本身就是一个令人惊叹的故事。她在自己小镇上的所作所为帮助改变了整个国家。以下是贾德带来的故事。
The story starts in the 1940s, Abeokuta, Nigeria, a town that is about 50 miles north of Lagos. In Yoruba, "Abeokuta" means "refuge under the rocks," because what you see at the center of town is this massive granite boulder. It's a really beautiful place.
故事始于 1940 年代的尼日利亚阿贝奥库塔 (Abeokuta)，一个位于拉各斯以北约 50 英里的城镇。在约鲁巴语中，“Abeokuta”的意思是“岩石下的避难所”，因为你在镇中心看到的是这块巨大的花岗岩巨石。这是一个非常美丽的地方。
And the British felt that Abeokuta was their crown jewel, really proof that the colonial project was working. Everything in Abeokuta was exactly as they wanted it. And our main character, Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti, Fela Kuti's mother, she was kind part of that system, at least initially. She taught at a very Christian, very British prep school--
英国人认为阿贝奥库塔是他们的皇冠宝石，是殖民项目行之有效的证据。阿贝奥库塔的一切都完全符合他们的意愿。我们的主角，费拉·库蒂的母亲富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂，最初在某种程度上也是那个系统的一部分。她在一家非常基督教、非常英式的预科学校任教——
Is this it, you think?
你觉得是这里吗？
--that is still there today.
——那所学校今天还在那里。
Abeokuta Grammar School.
阿贝奥库塔文法学校。
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
When we visited, we saw hundreds of small kids in Christian prep uniforms, little boys in yellow shirts and ties, little girls in checked skirts. And everywhere we went, about 20 young people, ages 12 to about 15, stared at us, very confused why we were there.
我们去的时候，看到几百个穿着基督教预科学校制服的小孩，穿着黄色衬衫和领带的小男孩，穿着方格裙的小女孩。无论我们走到哪里，大约 20 个 12 到 15 岁的年轻人都在盯着我们看，非常困惑我们为什么在那里。
Hello.
你好。
Can I talk to you for a minute?
能和你聊一会儿吗？
Yes.
好的。
Do you know Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti?
你知道富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂吗？
Yes.
知道。
What do you know about her?
你了解她什么？
(SUBJECT) BRITTANY RAMOS
(受访者) 布列塔尼·拉莫斯
She's the first woman to drive a car?
她是第一个开车女性？
Yes.
是的。
This is something you hear a lot. And, in fact, her car is on display at a museum in town.
这是你经常听到的说法。事实上，她的车在镇上的一家博物馆展出。
What do they teach you about her at the school?
学校教了你们关于她的什么？
She's a teacher.
她是老师。
And a woman leader.
也是一位女性领袖。
She's a teacher and a woman leader.
她是老师和女性领袖。
Sir?
先生？
Yes.
在。
She was the first woman to stop the pain of tax of women.
她是第一个停止女性税收之痛的女性。
To stop the pain of tax of women.
为了停止女性的税收之痛。
Yes.
是的。
Boom! That's the story we're going to tell on the radio.
太棒了！这就是我们要在广播里讲的故事。
Yes.
好的。
OK. Last question. Last question. Do you have an anthem for Abeokuta Grammar School?
最后一个问题。最后一个问题。你们有阿贝奥库塔文法学校的校歌吗？
Yes.
有的。
Can you sing it for us?
能为我们唱一下吗？
Yes.
可以。
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[外语歌唱]
OK, scene, set, done. It's the 1940s. Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti and her husband are running the grammar school. If you see pictures of her from this era, she dresses in almost Victorian style clothing-- puffy sleeves, buttons going down the front. She reminds you of the person you knew at school who is president of all the clubs.
好的，场景设置好了，完成。那是 1940 年代。富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂和她的丈夫经营着文法学校。如果你看到她那个时代的照片，她穿着近乎维多利亚风格的服装——蓬松的袖子，前襟上有纽扣。她让你想起你在学校里认识的那个担任所有俱乐部主席的人。
Colonialism had basically created this whole new class of Nigerian elite who worked with the British. And she was basically that, at least at first.
殖民主义基本上创造了一个全新的尼日利亚精英阶层，他们与英国人合作。她基本上就是那样，至少最初是这样。
The first organization that she creates is actually an organization to teach Christian girls how to be good wives.
她创建的第一个组织实际上是一个教导基督教女孩如何成为好妻子的组织。
This is historian Judith Byfield. She showed me photocopies of handwritten notes from Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti archives.
这位是历史学家朱迪思·拜菲尔德 (Judith Byfield)。她给我看了富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂档案中手写笔记的复印件。
Minutes of the Abeokuta Ladies Club.
阿贝奥库塔妇女俱乐部会议记录。
It's called the Abeokuta Ladies Club.
它被称为阿贝奥库塔妇女俱乐部。
Are these the actual minutes from 1945?
这些是 1945 年实际的会议记录吗？
Yeah, and, actually, I have a couple more envelopes. Make yourself comfortable.
是的，实际上，我还有几个信封。请随意点。
They were planning picnics.
她们当时正在计划野餐。
Picnic at 10:00 AM to 4:00 PM on the 31st. God, we have a whole dance program here.
31 日上午 10 点到下午 4 点野餐。天哪，我们这儿有一整个舞蹈节目。
They were planning dances.
她们当时正在计划跳舞。
Foxtrot, Hokey Pokey. Wow.
狐步舞，霍基波基舞。哇。
They were planning cookery classes. They were talking about how to recruit--
她们当时正在计划烹饪课程。她们在谈论如何招募——
It was again suggested that more ladies should be asked to join the club.
再次建议应该邀请更多女士加入俱乐部。
--for the next set of girls.
——下一批女孩。
That's her handwriting right there. Wow, very loopy, precise cursive. F. Ransome-Kuti, President. It's a weird thing when you see someone's handwriting.
那就是她的笔迹。哇，非常卷曲、精确的草书。F. 兰索姆-库蒂，主席。看到某人的笔迹是一件很奇怪的事情。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
They're there suddenly.
她们突然就在那里了。
And it turns out reading and writing would become one of the things, one of the catalytic agents that would take Funmilayo from cooking classes to coup plotting.
事实证明，阅读和写作将成为导致富米拉约从烹饪课转向政变策划的催化剂之一。
So--
所以——
This is historian Cheryl Johnson-Odom. She says it started one day in church.
这位是历史学家谢丽尔·约翰逊-奥多姆 (Cheryl Johnson-Odom)。她说这一切始于教堂的一天。
She said she was in church one time, and there was a market woman friend of hers who was singing but holding the hymnal upside down. And she said that was when she realized she couldn't read. And she just learned the words. So she said the market women, because of the little group she had, started coming to her.
她说有一次她在教堂，她的一个市场妇女朋友在唱歌，但把赞美诗集拿倒了。她说就在那时她意识到那个朋友不识字。那个朋友只是记住了歌词。所以她说，由于她有那个小团体，市场妇女们开始来找她。
We can imagine after the service, Fumilayo told the woman, hey, I have this club, why don't you come. We'll teach you--
我们可以想象礼拜结束后，富米拉约告诉那个女人，嘿，我有个俱乐部，你怎么不来呢。我们会教你——
--how to read.
——如何阅读。
This woman was not the kind of person who would have typically gone to the ladies club.
这个女人不是那种通常会去妇女俱乐部的人。
So the ladies club where all these elite Christian women.
所以妇女俱乐部里都是这些精英基督教女性。
She worked in the markets.
她在市场工作。
Very different class.
非常不同的阶层。
We might guess that she sold dyed cloth.
我们可能会猜她卖染布。
A tie dyer.
扎染匠。
Judith says that was a major industry in Abeokuta. The market women would use indigo dye to create these very particular undulating patterns that look like water.
朱迪思说那是阿贝奥库塔的一个主要产业。市场妇女会使用靛蓝染料来创造这些看起来像水的非常独特的起伏图案。
Pretty soon, all of the cloth dyers, and the rice sellers, and the red pepper sellers, and the potato sellers were all coming to Funmilayo's ladies club for reading lessons.
很快，所有的布料染色工、大米销售商、红辣椒销售商和土豆销售商都来到富米拉约的妇女俱乐部上阅读课。
In fact, Wole Soyinka, he's written about how he would sometimes be at her compound.
事实上，沃莱·索因卡 (Wole Soyinka) 写过他有时会待在她的院子里。
Women of every occupation, the cloth dyers, weavers, basket makers, they arrived in ones, twos, groups. They came from near and distant compounds. They smelled of the sweat of the journey, of dyes, dried fish, yam flour. In addition to the head tie, their shoulder shawls, neatly folded, were placed lightly on their heads.
各种职业的女性，染色工、织布工、编篮工，她们三五成群地到来。她们来自附近和遥远的院落。她们身上带着旅途的汗水、染料、干鱼、山药粉的味道。除了头巾，她们折叠整齐的肩巾轻轻地放在头上。
Well, you saw the swirling colors and the womem's sashes.
你看，你看到了旋转的色彩和女性的腰带。
That's Nobel Prize-winning writer Wole Soyinka, who is actually Fela Kuti's cousin. He spent a lot of time around Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti and has written about her extensively.
那是诺贝尔奖得主作家沃莱·索因卡，他实际上是费拉·库蒂的堂兄。他在富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂身边待了很多时间，并广泛地写过她。
You saw the movement of the clothing, which meant get out of my way.
你看到了衣服的运动，那意味着“让开”。
He talked about them being the wrapper wearers. He said when the wrapper wearers showed up, boy, something was going down.
他谈到她们是“裹裙佩戴者”。他说当那些裹裙佩戴者出现时，天哪，有大事要发生了。
And so the ladies club then sets up this literacy program, and Fela is involved.
所以妇女俱乐部随后设立了这个扫盲计划，费拉也参与了其中。
Fela, apparently, would sit with the cloth makers and the peanut sellers, and he would teach them how to write their letters.
费拉显然会和布料制造商和花生销售商坐在一起，教她们如何写信。
Wole Soyinka is involved. They're all helping to teach the market women to write.
沃莱·索因卡也参与其中。他们都在帮忙教市场妇女写作。
Well, as I confessed, I was a great eavesdropper as a child.
正如我坦白的那样，我小时候是个伟大的窃听者。
Wole Soyinka said that, inevitably, after the reading and writing lessons, the talk would turn to politics, and the kids would have to leave the room. But he, and we might imagine Fela next to him, they would crouch down and listen just out of sight. And when they did, he says, they would hear the same words coming up over and over.
沃莱·索因卡说，不可避免地，在读写课之后，谈话就会转向政治，孩子们不得不离开房间。但他，我们可以想象费拉也在他身边，他们会蹲下身子，在视线之外倾听。他说，当他们这样做时，他们会一遍又一遍地听到同样的词。
Taxes.
税收。
Taxes. Taxes. Taxes. Taxes. Taxes.
税收。税收。税收。税收。税收。
And also--
还有——
The Alake.
阿拉克 (The Alake)。
The Alake. The Alake.
阿拉克。阿拉克。
The Alake of Abeokuta was a formidable personality in his own right.
阿贝奥库塔的阿拉克本身就是一个令人生畏的人物。
This person, the Alake, is going to come up a lot, so let me explain the situation and who he was. Nigeria was a British colony, which we know. But colonialism took many forms. Unlike, say, South Africa, the Brits in Nigeria didn't have many white people on the ground. Instead, what they did was they ruled Nigeria through surrogates, like the Alake.
这个人，阿拉克，会出现很多次，所以让我解释一下情况以及他是谁。我们知道，尼日利亚是英国的殖民地。但殖民主义有许多种形式。与南非不同，尼日利亚的英国人并没有很多白人。相反，他们通过像阿拉克这样的代理人来统治尼日利亚。
The Alake, which is the king of this town.
阿拉克，也就是这个城镇的国王。
Technically, the Alake was a king, and he definitely looks like it. In one photo of him, he's decked out in flowing robes with gold detailing, big crown studded with jewels, and someone is always holding a fringed umbrella over his head.
从技术上讲，阿拉克是一位国王，而且他看起来也确实如此。在他的一张照片中，他穿着饰有金色细节的飘逸长袍，戴着镶满珠宝的大皇冠，而且总有人在他头上撑着一把流苏雨伞。
But if you look to the side of the picture, you see a white guy with a mustache and a shiny top hat. In most photos of the Alake, there is a guy like that standing right at the edge of the picture.
但如果你看照片的侧面，你会看到一个留着胡子、戴着闪亮高礼帽的白人。在阿拉克的大多数照片中，总有一个这样的人站在照片的边缘。
Basically, the Alake is being told what to do by the British, and he's being held in power by the British. And the decision making is British, even if it comes out of the Alake's mouth.
基本上，阿拉克被英国人告知该做什么，并且他被英国人控制在位。决策是英国人的，即使这些决策是从阿拉克的嘴里说出来的。
This was the basis of indirect rule. That was what the British said was so important about their system that they left those Indigenous political leaders, or titles at least, in place.
这就是“间接统治”的基础。英国人声称他们的系统之所以如此重要，是因为他们保留了那些土著政治领袖，或者至少保留了头衔。
This is why the British loved Abeokuta so much, because it was the perfect case study for their classic move. British government did this all over Asia in what is now Singapore, India, Bangladesh, and, of course, Africa. They would go in, take control of the leaders, and then use a local man dressed ostentatiously to execute their plans.
这就是为什么英国人如此喜爱阿贝奥库塔，因为它是他们经典操作的完美案例研究。英国政府在亚洲的今日新加坡、印度、孟加拉国，当然还有非洲，到处都这样做。他们会进入，夺取领袖的控制权，然后利用一个穿着华丽的当地人来执行他们的计划。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: OK, so full confession-- I'm not really supposed to be recording in here. This is his diary from 1912 to 1915.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什 (Ruby Walsh)：好的，彻底坦白——我其实不应该在这里录音。这是他 1912 年到 1915 年的日记。
Our producer, Ruby Walsh, found a diary of one colonial officer who put it pretty plainly.
我们的制片人鲁比·沃尔什发现了一位殖民官员的日记，他讲得很直白。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: The titular ruler is the Alake, who knows no English and started life as a canoe boy. However, the British commissioner, Mr. Young, is, of course, the dominating factor. The little state is somewhat in the position of a would-be independent, but really very dependent, child.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：名义上的统治者是阿拉克，他不懂英语，起初是个划独木舟的男孩。然而，英国专员杨先生显然是决定性的因素。这个小国在某种程度上处于一个想成为独立国家，但实际上非常依赖的孩子的境地。
Getting back to the story, the market women coming to those literacy meetings were pissed. Because around 1938, the British colonial officers, those men in suits at the margins of the photos, they went to the Alake and told him, we need you to tax the women in the market. Because at that time--
回到故事，来参加那些扫盲会议的市场妇女们非常愤怒。因为大约在 1938 年，英国殖民官员，也就是照片边缘那些穿着西装的人，去找阿拉克，告诉他，我们需要你向市场里的女性征税。因为在那时——
[SIREN WAILING]
[警笛长鸣]
Germany has invaded Poland and has bombed many towns.
德国入侵了波兰并轰炸了许多城镇。
--World War II was about to happen. Hitler was rampaging his way through Europe.
——第二次世界大战即将爆发。希特勒正在欧洲横冲直撞。
General mobilization has been ordered in Britain and France.
英国和法国已下达总动员令。
And this is something that no one teaches you in history class, but a lot of the manpower for the war effort came from European colonies in Africa.
历史课上没人教过这一点，但战争努力的大部分人力来自非洲的欧洲殖民地。
The people of Africa are doing excellent work to help the Allied cause, both by the production of raw materials and by finding men for the armed forces.
非洲人民正在为盟军的事业做出卓越的贡献，无论是通过生产原材料还是通过为武装部队寻找人员。
You saw the soldiers being moved across Abeokuta in lorries, and they were going to fight some nasty man called Adolf Hitler, the big ogre overseas, who, in some way or the other, was involved in our own local politics on the wrong side.
你看到士兵们被运过阿贝奥库塔，他们要去和那个叫阿道夫·希特勒的讨厌家伙作战，那个海外的大魔王，他以某种方式参与了我们当地的政治，而且是站在错误的一边。
This was happening all over Africa. You had the Nigeria regiment. You had stations on the shore of Sierra Leone. You had the Gold Coast regiment. And so the British government now had this problem.
这种情况在整个非洲都在发生。你有尼日利亚军团。你在塞拉利昂海岸有驻地。你有黄金海岸军团。所以英国政府现在遇到了这个问题。
They're trying just to make sure they get enough rice to feed the soldiers. And so there are all these conversations about how can we, in a sense, put more of a squeeze on the population? It's a really combustible situation for these market women.
他们只是想确保有足够的稻米来养活士兵。因此，关于我们如何在某种意义上对人口施加更大压力的对话随处可见。对这些市场妇女来说，这是一个非常容易点燃的局面。
What the British decided to do was create a contingent of tax collectors. These were native tax collectors, so non-white. But like the Alake, they were directed by the British colonial officers.
英国人决定建立一支税务官队伍。这些是当地的税务官，也就是非白人。但像阿拉克一样，他们受英国殖民官员的指挥。
They were hated. They were hated. They were considered the slaves of white district officers.
他们被恨之入骨。他们被认为是白人区官员的奴隶。
The tax collectors would march in to the markets, demand that the market sellers unload all their potatoes and their rice for a third of what they were asking.
税务官会冲进市场，要求市场卖家以她们要价的三分之一卸下所有的土豆和大米。
And if you don't sell to me, I'll actually just confiscate it, and you get nothing. So during the war, they had no control over the prices.
如果你不卖给我，我实际上会直接没收它，那你什么都得不到。所以在战争期间，她们无法控制价格。
On top of that, the tax collectors would levy all these new fines on the women.
最重要的是，税务官会向妇女征收各种新的罚款。
Not only tax them, but make sure they pay.
不仅向她们征税，还要确保她们交纳。
So at those literacy meetings, the market woman would tell Funmilayo these stories about how they were being harassed, how they would try to sell at night to avoid the tax collectors but often get caught.
所以在那些扫盲会议上，市场妇女会告诉富米拉约这些故事，关于她们是如何被骚扰的，她们如何尝试在晚上卖东西以避开税务官，但经常被抓。
Taken to court and tried and sometimes get hard labor. They were putting them in jail. At one point, they started jailing them outside of Abeokuta so that their families couldn't see them.
被带到法庭受审，有时会被判苦役。他们把她们关进监狱。有一次，他们开始把她们关在阿贝奥库塔外面，这样她们的家人就看不到她们了。
Wole Soyinka writes about one literary meeting where an old woman got up to speak.
沃莱·索因卡写过一次扫盲会议，一位老妇人站起来发言。
She was so old that she had to be assisted up. The meeting was her first, and she had dragged her feeble body to the assembly as a last hope for the menace now hanging over her head. She tells her story.
她太老了，必须有人扶着。那次会议是她的第一次，她拖着虚弱的身体来到集会上，这是她头顶上悬着的威胁的最后一线希望。她讲述了自己的故事。
Her son died and left 13 children behind, so she took over the farm to provide for them. Then, tax officers came to her and said, because she has a large farm, she gets a special assessment, asking for far more money than she has ever had.
她的儿子去世了，留下了 13 个孩子，所以她接管了农场来抚养他们。然后，税务人员来找她，说因为她有一个大农场，她得到了特别评估，要求支付比她以往拥有的多得多的钱。
You know, one of the things that the colonial enterprise did was it made assumptions about the way society was organized and structured. It made assumptions about women. For instance, it went into the marketplace, and it started telling women where they could locate their markets. Well, nobody told women where they could locate their markets, not even African men.
你知道，殖民企业所做的事情之一就是对社会组织和结构的方式做出假设。它对女性做出假设。例如，它进入市场，开始告诉女性她们可以在哪里放置市场。好吧，没有人告诉女性她们可以在哪里放置市场，即使是非洲男性也没有。
Because there was a really different status between the public status of women and the private status of women. And private women were, I'd say, generally oppressed by Indigenous patriarchy. In public, it was like a whole different thing.
因为女性的公共地位和女性的私人地位之间存在着非常大的差异。而在私人领域，女性我认为通常受到土著父权制的压迫。在公共场合，这完全是另一回事。
I mean, I saw a woman-- I don't tell this story often-- who was telling everybody what to do in the market-- you know, blah, blah, blah, blah-- men, too. But I went to her house one time, and she was serving her husband on her knees. And I'm like, this can't be you. This cannot be you.
我的意思是，我见过一个女人——我不常讲这个故事——她在市场里告诉所有人该做什么——你知道，巴拉巴拉什么的——也包括男人。但我有一次去她家，她跪着侍奉她的丈夫。我说，这不可能是你。这绝对不可能是你。
And so the colonial enterprise began interfering with what had been the traditional rights of women-- where to decide where a market went, how much to charge for something. And so the women began to get very agitated.
所以殖民企业开始干扰女性的传统权利——决定市场在哪里，某样东西收多少钱。因此，女性开始变得非常激动。
All of which is to say that as the meetings went on, the nature of the relationship between Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti and these market women began to shift. At first, it was just reading lessons. But then, the market women began to approach her and ask her if she would write letters for them, letters to the Alake, to the British colonial officials.
所有这一切都是说，随着会议的进行，富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂与这些市场妇女之间的关系性质开始发生转变。起初，这只是阅读课。但后来，市场妇女开始接近她，请求她为她们写信，写给阿拉克，写给英国殖民官员的信。
Wow.
哇。
So where we are right now used to be her study-- Funmilayo's study.
所以我们现在所处的地方曾经是她的书房——富米拉约的书房。
We took a tour of her house, a small, two-story house with a balcony overlooking a busy street. And our tour guide--
我们参观了她的房子，一栋小型两层建筑，阳台俯瞰着繁忙的街道。我们的导游——
My name is Aki Labi. I'm the manager at the Kuti Heritage Museum.
我叫阿基·拉比 (Aki Labi)。我是库蒂遗产博物馆的经理。
--showed us her home office, a spare room, tiny rug, chair.
——向我们展示了她的家庭办公室，一个备用房间，小地毯，椅子。
These are our original furnitures that we had to refurbish.
这些是我们必须翻新的原始家具。
Is that an original turntable there?
那里有一个原始的转盘吗？
Oh, yeah, it is.
噢，是的，确实是。
Wow. What would she-- she'd probably listen to hymns, would you guess?
哇。她会——你会猜她会听赞美诗吗？
Yeah.
是的。
There was an old wooden desk facing out the window, and it was very easy to imagine her sitting there typing, just rifling off the hundreds of letters found in her archives.
有一张旧木书桌对着窗户，很容易想象她坐在那里打字，随意处理着档案中发现的数百封信件。
The Igbo women's suffering is becoming unbearable. Igbo women have been summoned, worried, harangued, and ill treated by tax collectors. They said the soup they were given would not be eaten by dogs.
伊博族妇女的苦难变得难以忍受。伊博族妇女被税务官传唤、担忧、责骂和虐待。她们说给她们喝的汤连狗都不会吃。
They had to spread their blankets out to sleep on. Young girls are sometimes stripped naked in the streets by the men, officially designated collectors, in order to ascertain whether they are mature enough to pay tax or not. A woman was jailed with a 9-day-old baby after she had paid her tax to the tax collector.
她们不得不铺开毯子睡觉。年轻女孩有时会在街上被官方指定的税务官剥光衣服，以确定她们是否已经成熟到可以纳税。一名妇女在向税务官缴税后，带着一个 9 天大的婴儿被关进监狱。
Back with Judith.
回到朱迪思那里。
All right, so this is a letter to Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti from, I guess, an officer.
好的，这是一封写给富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂的信，我想，来自一位官员。
In one exchange about that jailed woman, an officer replied.
在关于那个被关押妇女的一次交流中，一位官员回复了。
My Dear Mrs. Kuti, what does it matter if a woman is jailed with a day-old baby? What we want to know is that she pays her tax.
亲爱的库蒂夫人，一个女人带着一天的婴儿被关进监狱又有什么关系呢？我们想知道的是她是否纳税。
Wow.
哇。
So they were taking these stories to Ransome-Kuti, and then Ransome-Kuti would try to talk to the Alake on their behalf. He would basically say, there's nothing I can do.
所以她们把这些故事告诉了兰索姆-库蒂，然后兰索姆-库蒂会尝试代表她们与阿拉克交谈。他基本上会说，我无能为力。
He'd say you have to talk to the British. This is their policy.
他会说你必须跟英国人谈。这是他们的政策。
And she was like, we have exhausted all these channels. We go to the colonial officials. They tell us it's the Alake. They go to him, and he says, it's not me. It's the colonial officials who you have to talk to. They have had it. They're like, this run around has to stop.
她当时的态度是，我们已经穷尽了所有这些渠道。我们去找殖民官员。他们告诉我们是阿拉克。她们去找他，他说，不是我。你们必须跟殖民官员谈。她们受够了。她们觉得，这种跑腿必须停止。
Wole Soyinka remembers the moment when the vibe irrevocably shifted. It happened at the grammar school.
沃莱·索因卡记得那种氛围发生不可逆转转变的时刻。它发生在文法学校。
A tumult overspilled the courtyard.
一阵骚动涌出了庭院。
Market women had come from all over.
市场妇女从各地赶来。
There was no question of my going home that night. I sensed the beginning of an unusual event and was gripped by the excitement. The women's group met till late. I had long fallen asleep on the bench in the dining room, and woke up the following morning in a bed in the dormitory of Mrs. Kuti's class. On the following morning, at breakfast, I heard for the first time the expression Abeokuta Women's Union.
那天晚上我不可能回家。我感觉到了一件不寻常事件的开始，并被那种兴奋感所笼罩。妇女团体开会到很晚。我早已在餐厅的长椅上睡着了，第二天早上在库蒂夫人的课堂宿舍的床上醒来。第二天早上，在早餐时，我第一次听到了“阿贝奥库塔妇女联盟”(Abeokuta Women's Union) 这个词。
The Abeokuta Women's Union.
阿贝奥库塔妇女联盟。
Wow, this is a--
哇，这是一个——
At this point in the archives, you see a switch flip. No more ladies club. This is a union. And no more Western clothes. From this point forward, she would dress in the same wraps and headscarves as the market women.
在档案的这一点，你看到开关打开了。不再有妇女俱乐部了。这是一个联盟。不再有西式服装。从这一点开始，她开始穿着与市场妇女相同的裹裙和头巾。
She started only wearing Nigerian clothing. She never wore Western clothing again.
她开始只穿尼日利亚服装。她再也没有穿过西式服装。
OK, this is constitutional rules and regulations, aims and objectives of the unions-- to establish and maintain unity and cooperation among all women in Igboland.
好的，这是宪法规则和条例，联盟的目的和目标——在所有伊博族妇女中建立和维持团结与合作。
Igboland, by the way, is a reference to one of the dominant ethnic groups in Nigeria.
顺便说一句，伊博族土地是指尼日利亚占主导地位的族群之一。
To cooperate with all organizations seeking and fighting genuinely and selflessly for the economic and political freedom and independence of the people. Dang. Number 5-- to raise and maintain necessary and adequate-- man, it's like I read this stuff, and I'm like, we've got to get our shit together. These people were organized.
与所有寻求并真诚、无私地为人民的经济和政治自由与独立而斗争的组织合作。该死。第 5 条——筹集和维持必要且充足的——天哪，我读这些东西，觉得我们必须把我们的一切整理好。这些人很有组织性。
And, you know, she had a car, so she used to drive to different communities and hold meetings with them.
而且，你知道，她有一辆车，所以她过去常常开车去不同的社区并与她们举行会议。
And we know, because Fela told it to his biographer, Carlos Moore, that when she got in a car to go to a meeting, she would often take him with her.
我们知道，因为费拉告诉了他的传记作者卡洛斯·摩尔，当她开车去开会时，她经常带上他。
So she and her husband owned this school. And so the school had huge grounds, and that's where the wrapper wearers would meet.
所以她和她丈夫拥有这所学校，学校有巨大的场地，这就是裹裙佩戴者聚会的地方。
While we were at the school, I kept looking into the fields behind where the kids were doing the Bible study. I mean, it wasn't the same field, but I kept trying to imagine what it would have looked like filled with thousands of women.
当我们在学校时，我一直看着孩子们正在学习圣经的地方后面的田野。我是说，那不是同一个田野，但我一直试图想象当它被成千上万的妇女填满时会是什么样子。
You know, there were-- the estimates are between 10,000 and 20,000 members.
你知道，有——估计有 1 万到 2 万名成员。
According to Wole Soyinka, the first protest happened almost spontaneously.
根据沃莱·索因卡的说法，第一次抗议几乎是自发发生的。
They poured out of the grammar school compound, filled the streets, and marched towards the palace of the Alake.
她们从文法学校的院落涌出，填满了街道，并向阿拉克的宫殿游行。
It was a bust. The authorities quickly shut it down and jailed Funmilayo, saying she didn't have a permit to march. When she was released, she thought, OK, fine. If you're not going to let us have a protest--
那是一次惨败。当局迅速将其取缔并监禁了富米拉约，称她没有游行许可。当她被释放时，她想，好的，好吧。如果你不让我们进行抗议——
They said they were going to have a picnic. So they gathered 10,000 women to go have a picnic. And they were carrying little packets of food.
她们说她们要举行野餐。所以她们召集了 1 万名妇女去野餐。她们带着小包的食物。
A week before, Funmilayo had held a massive meeting in her courtyard.
一周前，富米拉约在她的院子里举行了一次大规模的会议。
And she said it at her compound. She came out, and she said to them-- and she said she was screaming because there were so many of them. Because she started talking, and they were like, in the back, I can't hear you. So she was screaming through her hands.
她在她的院子里说了。她出来，对她们说——她说她在尖叫，因为那里有太多人。因为她开始说话，她们在后面说，我听不见。所以她用双手做喇叭尖叫。
And she was saying, look. This is the time. I'm going to turn my back to you, and anybody who wants to can scurry away. I won't know who you are. I won't see you.
她说，看。现在是时候了。我要背对着你们，任何想走的人都可以溜走。我不会知道你是谁。我不会看到你。
Whoa.
哇。
But when I turn back around, everybody I see better be on board. And so she turned her back. And according to everybody, nobody left.
但当我转过身时，我看到的每一个人最好都跟我站在同一边。于是她背过身去。据大家所说，没有人离开。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
And then, as Wole Soyinka describes it, all at once, all 10,000 women took off their head wraps.
然后，正如沃莱·索因卡所描述的那样，一下子，所有 1 万名妇女都摘下了她们的头巾。
It was always a dramatic moment. Normally, there's a head tie nestling peacefully on the head. The moment there's going to be conflict, off would come the head tie to the waist.
那总是一个戏剧性的时刻。通常情况下，头巾平静地栖息在头上。一旦要发生冲突，头巾就会被摘下并系在腰间。
They would tie it around their waist like a belt.
她们会把它像腰带一样系在腰上。
It's like throwing down the gauntlet. When a woman takes off her head tie, ties it like a sash around her waist, men scatter.
这就像扔下手套。当一个女人摘下她的头巾，把它像腰带一样系在腰上时，男人们就会四散奔逃。
Oh, my god. You can see her addressing the crowd. What! Oh, wow. You can see the crowd.
噢，天哪。你可以看到她对人群讲话。什么！噢，哇。你可以看到人群。
After 3.5 hours of diggig through the archives that Judith Byfield had laid out for me, I found these black-and-white pictures.
在挖掘朱迪思·拜菲尔德为我准备的档案 3.5 小时后，我发现了这些黑白照片。
There's literally like 10,000 people, 10,000 heads.
这里面字面上大约有 1 万人，1 万个头。
In one picture, shot from above, you see thousands of heads covered in white scarves, white circles filling every millimeter of the picture. And to the side, on a platform, one woman addresses them. And next to her, maybe a young boy? Probably. I'm just imagining it. I'm getting a little too excited.
在一张从上方拍摄的照片中，你看到成千上万个戴着白色头巾的头，白色的圆圈填满了照片的每一毫米。而在侧面，在一个平台上，一个女人对她们讲话。在她旁边，可能是一个小男孩？很可能是。我只是在想象。我太兴奋了。
Oh, my God, these pictures.
噢，天哪，这些照片。
This rally is perhaps the moment right before they march to the Alake's palace, which is when things really go down.
这次集会也许就是她们游行前往阿拉克宫殿之前的那一刻，那时候事情真的发生了。
My sense of it is you would see this sea of women approaching the palace.
我的感觉是，你会看到这片妇女的海洋逼近宫殿。
What you would see is you would see men getting out of the way. And they would often tell the British. The British would come to them and say, get these women to stop it. And they would say, we don't tell the market women what to do. We cannot stop it.
你会看到的是，你会看到男人们让开路。他们经常告诉英国人。英国人会来找他们说，让这些妇女停止抗议。他们会说，我们不告诉市场妇女该做什么。我们无法阻止它。
And there's a wonderful passage in Aké, where Soyinka talks about one of the chiefs running into his mother's shop and hiding there, because the women had stripped him of his clothes and just reduced him to his underwear.
在《阿凯》(Aké) 中有一个美妙的段落，索因卡谈到其中一位酋长冲进他母亲的商店并躲在那里，因为妇女们剥光了他的衣服，只剩下内衣。
Speaking of Wole Soyinka, he snuck ahead of the women to the palace, which we visited. Picture a gated mansion painted canary yellow. He snaked through the gate, under the stone archway, and into this spacious square.
说到沃莱·索因卡，他溜到妇女们前面去了宫殿，我们也参观了那里。想象一座漆成金丝雀黄色的大门宅邸。他钻过大门，穿过石拱门，进入了这个宽敞的广场。
OK, we're in the-- this must have been the courtyard where they were. It's a big open space with peacocks milling about.
好的，我们在——这一定是她们所在的院子。这是一个很大的开放空间，有孔雀在徘徊。
[PEACOCK SQUAWKING]
[孔雀叫声]
As you walk into the courtyard, you see a building in front of you, yellow building.
当你走进院子时，你会在前面看到一座建筑，黄色建筑。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: There's an image of them talking to the Alake, and the Alake coming down from a balcony. That might have been the balcony.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：有一张她们与阿拉克交谈的图像，阿拉克从阳台上走下来。那可能就是那个阳台。
That's probably the balcony.
那很可能是那个阳台。
Up high, there was a single balcony with glass doors, the Alake's bedroom. He initially stayed inside as the women flooded the courtyard.
在高处，有一个带玻璃门的单一阳台，是阿拉克的卧室。当妇女们涌入庭院时，他最初待在里面。
So they were probably right here. You'd just see a sea of white headscarves.
所以她们可能就在这里。你会看到一片白色头巾的海洋。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: Absolutely.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：绝对是的。
At first, some of the Alake's junior chiefs come outside and try and hold the women back to keep them from entering. They comply, but only in exchange for a conversation with the Alake. So the juniors go inside. Then, the glass doors on that balcony opened, and the Alake stepped out, dressed in his gold robes.
起初，阿拉克的一些初级酋长走出来，试图阻挡妇女，防止她们进入。她们配合了，但条件是必须与阿拉克交谈。所以初级酋长进去了。然后，那个阳台上的玻璃门打开了，阿拉克走了出来，穿着他的金色长袍。
When the Alake appeared, they curtsied, going down on their knees but no more. The Alake had obviously resolved to receive the emissaries courteously.
当阿拉克出现时，她们行了屈膝礼，跪在地上，但仅此而已。阿拉克显然决定礼貌地接待使者。
A protester, one of Mrs. Kuti's lieutenants, stepped forward and called up to the Alake.
一位抗议者，库蒂夫人的一名副官，走上前去，向阿拉克高声呼喊。
Kabiyesi: the message--
卡比耶西 (Kabiyesi)：这个信息——
The message which I bring you today is the message of all women who have left their stalls, their homes, and children, their farms and petty affairs to come and visit you today. They are the suffering crowd who are gathered on your front lawn. You can see them yourself, Kabiyesi. They are all the womanhood of Igbo.
我今天带给你的信息，是所有今天离开摊位、家庭、孩子、农场和琐事来看你的妇女的信息。她们是聚集在你前草坪上的受苦人群。你自己可以看到她们，卡比耶西。她们是所有伊博族的女性。
The voice with which I speak is the voice of our Bira, Mrs. Kuti. The words which you hear from me are the words of Mrs. Kuti. She asked me to tell you on behalf of those women you see outside that the women of Igbo have had enough.
我说话的声音，是我们比拉 (Bira)、库蒂夫人的声音。你从我这里听到的词，是库蒂夫人的词。她让我代表你在外面看到的那些妇女告诉你，伊博族的妇女受够了。
In hindsight, it was rather like protagonists and the chorus.
事后看来，这更像是主角和合唱队。
Wole Soyinka describes the scene almost like it had a kind of mythic choreography.
沃莱·索因卡描述的场景就像它有一种神话般的编排。
You had the massed women. You had the moment when the white district officer came in through the gates and was booed roundly.
你有聚集的妇女。你有白人区官员穿过大门被集体嘘声的那一刻。
A policeman ordered a district officer to clear his way through the crowd towards Mrs. Kuti. As he moved through, the women threw insults at him from all directions, getting in his face. Mrs. Kuti stayed rooted.
一名警察命令一名地区官员穿过人群走向库蒂夫人。当他穿过时，妇女们从四面八方对他投掷侮辱，贴到他脸上。库蒂夫人纹丝不动。
Officer-- look here, Mrs. Kuti. We are trying to hold a serious meeting here. Will you kindly keep your women in order?
官员——看这里，库蒂夫人。我们正试图在这里举行一次严肃的会议。你能请你的妇女们保持秩序吗？
(SUBJECT) NIGERIAN READER AS FUNMILAYO
(受访者) 尼日利亚读者饰演富米拉约
Officer-- well, tell them to shut up. Shut up your women.
官员——好吧，叫她们闭嘴。让你的人闭嘴。
Mrs. Kuti apparently squinted her eyes.
库蒂夫人显然眯起了眼睛。
I think her exact words were-- you may have been born, but you were not bred.
我想她的话原话是——你可能出生了，但你没有教养。
Those words would fly around Abeokuta for weeks.
那些话在阿贝奥库塔飞传了几个星期。
I think that's the one which then became translated that you lack bread in your house and all kinds of other versions. Anyway, she gave it to him back with interest.
我想那就是后来翻译成“你家里没面包”以及各种其他版本的那个。总之，她加倍奉还。
And it was at that point that the women began to sing.
就在那一刻，妇女们开始唱歌。
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[外语歌唱]
This is one of the most interesting parts of the story to me.
这是故事中我最感兴趣的部分之一。
Oh, look at this.
噢，看这个。
Yeah, this--
是的，这个——
All songs sung during the Women's Union demonstrations from Fort-- oh, hello. This is-- what?
妇女联盟游行期间唱的所有歌曲，从堡——噢，你好。这是——什么？
In the archives that Judith showed me, Fumilayo has documented all of the songs, the protest songs that the women sang when they occupied the palace.
在朱迪思给我看的档案中，富米拉约记录了所有的歌曲，也就是妇女们占领宫殿时唱的抗议歌曲。
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[外语歌唱]
First of all, there are a lot of these songs. There's 200 different songs they were singing.
首先，这些歌曲有很多。她们唱了 200 首不同的歌。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Every protest movement is defined by its music, to some degree, and there are pages and pages of these songs in the archives.
每一个抗议运动在某种程度上都由其音乐所定义，档案中有这些歌曲的几页又几页。
[NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[外语歌唱]
All the songs are in Yoruba, so we hired a language expert to help us translate them, and then a choir in Lagos to sing them. And these songs are wild.
所有的歌曲都是约鲁巴语，所以我们雇了一位语言专家来帮助我们翻译，然后请了拉各斯的一个合唱团来演唱它们。这些歌曲太野了。
Because they would sing insulting songs.
因为她们会唱侮辱性的歌曲。
And a quick warning, they get kind of graphic.
另外，快速警告一下，它们有点露骨。
They would say things like--
她们会说一些话，比如——
[CHANTING]
[咏唱]
You know, white man is not going to get back to his country alive. We're going to cut off the Aleke's head. The Alake's genitals are small. I mean, all kinds of just mean, mean things to just insult.
你知道，白人活着回不到他的国家。我们要砍掉阿拉克的头。阿拉克的生殖器很小。我的意思是，各种各样卑鄙、卑鄙的话来侮辱。
My favorite by far.
我最喜欢的一首。
[CHANTING]
[咏唱]
The chorus that we got to sing these songs were gasping when they read the lyrics.
我们请来唱这些歌的合唱团在读歌词时都倒吸了一口凉气。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[外语讲话]
English. English translation-- Alake that has the penis-- his penis is as big as a horse.
英语。英语翻译——那个有阴茎的阿拉克——他的阴茎和马一样大。
The Alake has a penis as big as a horse, however--
阿拉克有一个和马一样大的阴茎，然而——
His vagina Yeah. We will cut because--
他的阴道，是的。我们会切，因为——
[CHATTER]
[嘈杂声]
We will cut it off, basically. The literal translation is, as best as we can tell, we will emit fire from our vaginas that will wound his penis.
基本上，我们会切掉它。据我们所知，字面翻译是，我们会从阴道喷火，烧伤他的阴茎。
You can't. You can't translate them literally like exactly how it is.
你不能，你不能字面翻译它们，完全照字面翻译。
This is one of the reasons why the protest movement became known as Vengeance of the Vagina Head.
这就是为什么抗议运动被称为“阴道之首的复仇”的原因之一。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[外语讲话]
There is an African tradition called sitting on a man. Sitting on a man means gathering outside of a man's house and singing insulting, derisive songs, and daring him to come out. And men were scared to death of it.
非洲有一个传统叫“坐在男人身上”。“坐在男人身上”意味着聚集在一个男人的房子外面，唱侮辱性、嘲弄性的歌曲，并挑衅他出来。男人们被吓死了。
Now, no one woman could talk to her husband like that. So if a man beat a woman, she might run to her market women's group, and then they would descend in the hundreds on her house, telling her husband if he ever beat her again, they were going to deal with them.
现在，没有一个女人能那样跟她丈夫说话。所以如果一个男人打了一个女人，她可能会跑到她的市场妇女团体，然后她们会成百上千地降临到她家，告诉她丈夫如果他再打她，她们就会对付他们。
Wow.
哇。
So they would start singing those songs to the Alake.
所以她们会开始对阿拉克唱那些歌。
Yeah, they weren't mincing their words.
是的，她们没有委婉地表达。
And then they would say, and we're not leaving either.
然后她们会说，而且我们也哪儿都不去。
Coming up after the break, the women make the British experience something they have absolutely no answer for. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
休息后回来，妇女们让英国人体验了他们根本无法应对的事情。那将在芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续中，稍后就来。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Bigger Than Me," stories of people trying to rise to the historic moment that they find themselves in. If you're just tuning in, we're in the middle of an excerpt from Jad Abumrad's new podcast about Fela Kuti. This particular story is about Fela's mother, Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti. Jad picks up where he left off. The women are trying to convince the Alake to stop taxing them unfairly.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“比我伟大”，讲述人们试图挺身而出，迎接他们发现自己所处历史时刻的故事。如果你刚转台，我们正在摘录贾德·阿布姆拉德关于费拉·库蒂的新播客。这个特别的故事是关于费拉的母亲富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂。贾德从他中断的地方继续。妇女们正在试图说服阿拉克停止不公平地向她们征税。
The market women camped out in the courtyard of the Alake's palace, and then they began round-the-clock shifts. Wole Soyinka remembers that those encampments became like a city.
市场妇女露营在阿拉克宫殿的庭院里，然后她们开始了 24 小时轮班。沃莱·索因卡记得那些营地变得像一座城市。
There were moments of absolute stillness-- for instance, when they started cooking. Because they laid siege. They were there all night, and they took turns. Sometimes would go home, look after the children, and come back to their position. So there was cooking also and the activity, especially at night, when they lit their lamps, oil lamps, to stay on the siege.
有绝对静止的时刻——例如，当她们开始做饭时。因为她们围城了。她们整晚都在那里，轮流值班。有时会回家，照顾孩子，然后回到她们的阵地。所以还有做饭和活动，特别是在晚上，当她们点亮油灯，维持围城时。
At some point, you described yourself as a courier.
在某个阶段，你描述你自己是一名信使。
Yes, it's true. I was a courier since I was so small. And there were police, lots of police around and the Alake's own guards. Since I was so tiny, people didn't take much notice of me. And so Mrs. Kuti in particular--
是的，是真的。我从小就是一名信使。到处都是警察，很多警察和阿拉克自己的警卫。因为我太小了，人们不太注意到我。所以库蒂夫人特别——
He says she would entrust him with these notes.
他说她会委托他携带这些字条。
Little notes to her forces who were scattered in front of the palace.
给她在宫殿前分散的部队的小字条。
These protests happened on and off as the year went on.
这些抗议在这一年中时断时续地发生。
I mean, they literally made the town ungovernable.
我的意思是，她们实际上让这个城镇变得无法治理。
They shut down the market, and they stayed camped out just outside the Alake's window.
她们关闭了市场，并驻扎在阿拉克的窗外。
The sea of women is in the palace, and he can't get out.
妇女们的海洋在宫殿里，他出不去。
After several months of this, he starts to crack.
在经历了几个月的这种情况后，他开始崩溃。
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
And is he amassing soldiers to try and drive a wedge through the protesters?
他在集结士兵试图在抗议者中切开一条通道吗？
So that's a really interesting story. I learned from the memoir of the main colonial official that they did have soldiers on the edge of town, and they were contemplating bringing the soldiers into town. In fact, the Alake was trying to beg him to bring the soldiers in.
这是一个非常有趣的故事。我从主要殖民官员的回忆录中了解到，他们在城镇边缘确实有士兵，他们正在考虑把士兵带进城里。事实上，阿拉克一直在乞求他带士兵进来。
This is not theoretical. Almost 20 years earlier, in a different part of Nigeria, there had been a different revolt, also led by women.
这不是理论。将近 20 年前，在尼日利亚的另一个地方，发生了另一场起义，也是由女性领导的。
Also a struggle around taxation. And in the 29 protests, they did call out the army, and women were killed.
也是一场围绕税收的斗争。在 29 年的抗议中，他们确实调动了军队，妇女被杀害了。
Army opened fire on a crowd and killed over 50 women. A few years before that, in 1918, a similar rebellion ended up with 600 people dead. Fela would actually sing a song about this.
军队向人群开火并杀死了 50 多名妇女。在此之前的几年，即 1918 年，一场类似的叛乱导致 600 人死亡。费拉实际上会唱一首关于这个的歌。
[FELA KUTI SINGING]
[费拉·库蒂演唱]
He would adapt a folk song that was used in the protest and set it to music.
他会改编抗议中使用的民间歌曲，并将其谱曲。
[FELA KUTI SINGING]
[费拉·库蒂演唱]
But that's many years later. Let's not get ahead of ourselves. At that moment, if anything, Fela is in the encampment with his mom as the tension mounted, because it looked like this protest with the market women was going to end the same way as the others. Because what the Alake was saying, essentially, to his British masters was what you did last time, do it again, please.
但那是许多年后了。我们别操之过急。在那一刻，如果有的话，费拉正和他妈妈在营地里，随着紧张局势升级，因为看起来市场妇女的这次抗议会以同样的方式结束。因为阿拉克基本上是在对他的英国主子说，你们上次做的事，请再做一次。
They were very conscious of that earlier era. And so in the 47 now, they have the army close-- basically on the edge of town.
他们非常清楚那个早期时代。所以现在在 47 年，他们让军队靠近——基本上就在城镇边缘。
The market women are camped out, well aware of the violence that might be about to go down. But both Judith and Cheryl say that somewhere around this point in the standoff, the women begin to protest in an entirely new way. A few of them stepped forward.
市场妇女驻扎在那里，充分意识到可能即将发生的暴力事件。但朱迪思和谢丽尔都说，在对峙的这一点附近，妇女们开始以一种全新的方式抗议。她们中的几个人站了出来。
And they take their clothes off.
她们把衣服脱了。
They actually stripped naked.
她们实际上脱光了。
Apparently, right there in the plaza, some number of women-- we don't have accurate details on, maybe a dozen, maybe a hundred-- they got together and, while facing the Alake window all at once, they disrobed.
显然，就在广场上，一些妇女——我们没有准确的细节，也许是一打，也许是一百——她们聚集在一起，同时面对阿拉克的窗户，她们脱掉了衣服。
And the idea is that if you see an older woman naked, that's an abomination.
想法是，如果你看到一个年长的女人裸体，那是一种憎恶。
Judith explained that in many West African cultures, and, in fact, in many other cultures around the world, women disrobing, particularly older women, was thought of as a kind of weapon, a summoning of a spiritual power--
朱迪思解释说，在许多西非文化中，实际上在世界各地的许多其他文化中，女性脱掉衣服，特别是年长的女性，被认为是一种武器，一种召唤精神力量的方式——
Partly because of their ability to procreate, women are thought to be in touch with the spiritual powers around them and thought to be able to really weaponize that.
部分是因为她们的生育能力，女性被认为与周围的精神力量有联系，并被认为真正能够将这种力量武器化。
--that when they disrobed, any man who looked on them was now a target.
——当她们脱掉衣服时，任何看着她们的男人现在都是目标。
I find this moment so interesting. You have these women shoulder to shoulder, putting out a kind of spiritual power, almost like a force field. And then, just outside of town, you have an army.
我觉得这一刻非常有趣。你有这些肩并肩的妇女，发出一种精神力量，几乎就像一个力场。然后，就在城外，你有一支军队。
Yeah.
是的。
It's like two different epistemologies, in a way, of power.
这在某种意义上就像两种不同的权力认识论。
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
You have military power, and then you have this no less potent symbolic power.
你有军事力量，然后你有这种同样强大的象征力量。
Yeah.
是的。
And they're lined up against each other.
而且它们彼此对立。
Exactly. And so they have the army close, basically on the edge of town.
完全正确。所以他们让军队靠近，基本上就在城镇边缘。
And Judith says, if you read the correspondence that was flying back and forth between the Alake, and the generals, and between the various British officers, they were like, fuck. What do we do with this? We could march in, kill them all, as we've done before.
朱迪思说，如果你阅读阿拉克、将军和各位英国官员之间来回飞舞的信件，他们就像，该死。我们该怎么处理这个？我们可以进军，把她们全部杀掉，就像我们以前做过的那样。
But they're saying, do we want to create martyrs?
但他们说，我们想制造烈士吗？
The British understood on some level that women hold the culture of a place. They are traditionally the child rearers, the relationship tenders. So if you attack them--
英国人在某种程度上理解妇女掌握着一个地方的文化。她们传统上是孩子抚养者、关系维护者。所以如果你攻击她们——
If they go in and attack these women--
如果他们进去攻击这些妇女——
--that might unleash an energy that they can't contain.
——那可能会释放出一种他们无法遏制的能量。
--that could then bring young men and the ones you usually fear out into the streets as well.
——那可能会把年轻人和你们通常害怕的人也带到街上。
Don't forget, the British were outnumbered. They didn't actually have a lot of soldiers on the ground.
别忘了，英国人在人数上处于劣势。他们实际上在地面上并没有很多士兵。
And so on one hand, the state is a little hamstrung about how you deal with women.
所以一方面，国家在如何处理女性问题上有点束手束脚。
I think, in general, it's fair to say that a lot of politics is driven by the fact that men are afraid of women. In this case, the British definitely were.
我想，总的来说，可以说很多政治是由男人害怕女人这一事实所驱动的。在这种情况下，英国人绝对是。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: We lived in a constant strain, for we never knew when the pot would boil over.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：我们生活在持续的紧张状态中，因为我们永远不知道壶什么时候会烧开。
That is how John Blair, the main colonial officer stationed in Abeokuta, put it in his diary.
这就是驻扎在阿贝奥库塔的主要殖民官员约翰·布莱尔 (John Blair) 在日记中所写的话。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: When the tension was at its worst, I got quite ill, and the doctor sent me to hospital in Lagos. I was sure I was suffering from nervous exhaustion.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：当紧张局势最严重时，我病得很重，医生把我送到了拉各斯的医院。我确信我患的是神经衰弱。
On July 29, 1948, in the dead of night, as protesters were camped all around the palace, the British sent a car to the palace to take the Alake, his wives, and his family away.
1948 年 7 月 29 日，深夜，当抗议者驻扎在宫殿周围时，英国人派了一辆车到宫殿，把阿拉克、他的妻子和家人带走。
They snuck him out of town. He didn't want to leave.
他们把他偷偷带出了城。他不想走。
They snuck him past all the people?
他们把他偷偷从所有人身边带走了？
Yeah. They put him in a car. So one of the colonial officials I interviewed had been involved with getting him out of town. And he said they put him in the car and had him lie down on the back seat. So they were sneaking him out without the women being aware that he was leaving town.
是的。他们把他放进一辆车里。所以我采访过的一位殖民官员曾参与过把他弄出城。他说他们把他放进车里，让他躺在后座上。所以他们在妇女们没有察觉他要离开城镇的情况下偷偷把他带走了。
Wow.
哇。
He went into exile.
他流亡了。
OK, so this is a speech that the Alake made a few months after they took him away. After more than a half century of service--
好的，这是一段阿拉克在他们把他带走几个月后发表的演讲。在服务了半个多世纪之后——
(SUBJECT) NIGERIAN READER:
(受访者) 尼日利亚读者：
I cannot bear any longer the sight of turmoil, strife, and discontent.
我再也无法忍受这种动荡、冲突和不满的景象。
(SUBJECT) NIGERIAN READER:
(受访者) 尼日利亚读者：
Wow, quite a speech.
哇，真是个演讲。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In other words, he abdicated the throne.
换句话说，他退位了。
That was huge. No other woman is ever credited with unseating a sitting king.
这太大了。没有其他女性被认为曾经罢免过一位在位的国王。
Drumming began in the Olubunmi houses at 5:00 PM on August 21, 1948, followed by firing of guns by hunters and dance by all at Alake Square. 50 different forms of African dances were in attendance. They were dancing at the dawn of a new day.
1948 年 8 月 21 日下午 5 点，鼓声在 Olubunmi 的房子里响起，随后猎人们鸣枪，阿拉克广场上的所有人都在跳舞。50 种不同的非洲舞蹈参与其中。她们在曙光初现时跳舞。
They talked about Abeokuta being liberated. And they have this thanksgiving ceremony. There's this minister who speaks on behalf of the women. He said it took the women to do what the men couldn't do for 28 years.
她们谈论阿贝奥库塔被解放了。她们举行了这个感恩仪式。有位部长代表妇女讲话。他说，花了 28 年的时间，女性做到了男人做不到的事。
This just gives you a sense of this--
这只是让你感觉到了这个——
And in the archives, what you see from this point forward are hundreds of letters from other women.
在档案中，从这一点开始，你看到的是来自其他妇女的数百封信件。
She had letters in her paper from women all over the continent saying, Mother, you have so inspired us.
她的报纸里有来自整个大陆妇女的信，说，母亲，你太激励我们了。
1948, Dear Mrs. Kuti. I am penning you this day under the respect I owe to women.
1948 年，亲爱的库蒂夫人。我怀着对女性应有的尊重，今天给你写信。
Women from unions all over start to reach out.
来自各地的联盟的妇女开始联系。
We, the Alawa Oribe Women's Union, send this letter to ask for your assistance.
我们，Alawa Oribe 妇女联盟，写这封信是为了请求你的帮助。
Copycat women's unions start to appear everywhere.
模仿者的妇女联盟开始随处可见。
South Africa, the anti-apartheid movement, Ghana.
南非，反种族隔离运动，加纳。
Arab Women's Society, Union of Albanian Women, Union of Australian Women, Union of Korean Women.
阿拉伯妇女协会、阿尔巴尼亚妇女联盟、澳大利亚妇女联盟、朝鲜妇女联盟。
So you can look everywhere.
所以你可以随处看看。
Democratic League of Finnish Women, Democratic Union of German Women, Federation of Cuban Women, League for Lebanese Women Rights. Woo. Union of Luxembourg Women. And I'm only at the M's.
芬兰妇女民主联盟、德国民主妇女联盟、古巴妇女联合会、黎巴嫩妇女权利联盟。哇。卢森堡妇女联盟。我才读到 M。
And you see women everywhere.
你到处都能看到女性。
We in the West tend to emphasize the legacies of Africa's male leaders, the Kwame Nkrumahs the Nelson Mandelas. But if you look across the continent from this point forward, you see women leading revolts in Senegal, Cameroon, South Africa, Gold Coast, Algeria, Kenya, Mozambique, Ivory Coast, Togo, Mali, Somalia, Egypt. It's a story we've largely missed.
在西方，我们倾向于强调非洲男性领袖的遗产，比如夸梅·恩克鲁玛 (Kwame Nkrumah)，纳尔逊·曼德拉 (Nelson Mandela)。但如果你从这一点开始看整个大陆，你会看到妇女在塞内加尔、喀麦隆、南非、黄金海岸、阿尔及利亚、肯尼亚、莫桑比克、科特迪瓦、多哥、马里、索马里、埃及领导起义。这是一个我们很大程度上错过的故事。
And the erasure of it all kind of landed on us when we went off in search of Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti's grave. Aki, our tour guide from earlier, pointed us toward the Anglican church that was 300 feet from the house.
当我们去寻找富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂的墓地时，这一切的擦除感降临在我们身上。我们之前的导游阿基指引我们前往距离房子 300 英尺的圣公会教堂。
Yes, hi. We were told that Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti is buried in this church, or we're not sure which church.
是的，你好。我们被告知富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂埋在这个教堂里，或者我们不确定是哪个教堂。
We went there and asked around.
我们去了那里并四处打听。
[SPEAKING YORUBA]
[讲约鲁巴语]
The guy walked us to the back side of the church.
那个人带我们走到了教堂的后面。
This is--
这是——
Yeah, this one.
是的，这个。
This here?
这个吗？
Fela's mother is here. Fela's mother. Yes.
费拉的母亲在这里。费拉的母亲。是的。
Here we are.
我们到了。
There was a grave set in concrete. Mrs. Kuti is buried with her husband.
有一个用混凝土浇筑的坟墓。库蒂夫人和她丈夫埋在一起。
There's a headstone, and then above the headstone is a bust of Reverend Kuti.
有一个墓碑，在墓碑上方是库蒂牧师的半身像。
And there on the tombstone is his bust, and on the epitaph--
墓碑上有他的半身像，在墓志铭上——
Reverend Israel Oludotun Ransome-Kuti.
以色列·奥卢多通·兰索姆-库蒂 (Israel Oludotun Ransome-Kuti) 牧师。
--all the details of his life.
——他一生的所有细节。
President, Nigerian Union of Teachers Association, 1930 to 1954.
尼日利亚教师协会主席，1930 年至 1954 年。
He was a very impressive man--
他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人——
Commission on higher education.
高等教育委员会。
--did a lot to revolutionize the educational system in Nigeria. But his wife, who is buried with him and who led a revolt to depose the king, she's hardly mentioned.
——在尼日利亚的教育系统革命方面做了很多工作。但他的妻子，那个和他埋在一起并领导了一场罢黜国王起义的人，她几乎没有被提及。
It's crazy they didn't say anything about her.
他们没提她任何事，这太疯狂了。
Barely a word. All there is this one line that says, RIP, my love Funmilayo.
几乎没有一句话。所有这一切只有这一行字说，安息吧，我的爱人富米拉约。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: Are you surprised?
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：你感到惊讶吗？
A little bit. I was expecting her to have a thing.
有一点。我本以为她会有一个专门的东西。
(SUBJECT) RUBY WALSH: Me, too.
(受访者) 鲁比·沃尔什：我也是。
Yeah, that says a lot.
是的，那说明了很多。
Even people who do remember her, says Judith, tend to think of her as a footnote in Fela's story, rather than the hero of her own.
即使是记得她的人，朱迪思说，也倾向于认为她是费拉故事中的脚注，而不是她自己故事的英雄。
I so appreciate that you're doing this, though, because that's the thing that drove me crazy. She became reduced to Fela's mother. And so even when I would give talks in Nigeria, people would be surprised at all the stuff that I bring out. Because her activism has just really been forgotten.
尽管如此，我非常感谢你在做这件事，因为那是让我发疯的事情。她沦为了费拉的母亲。所以即使我在尼日利亚发表演讲，人们也会对我提出的所有东西感到惊讶。因为她的激进主义真的被遗忘了。
Fela Kuti himself would eventually take up positions about the role of women in society that were very controversial and, in many ways, flew in the face of what his mother was fighting for. And yet, he did honor her. He referred to her as the Mother of Nigeria.
费拉·库蒂本人最终采取了关于女性在社会中作用的立场，这些立场非常有争议，并且在许多方面与他母亲所争取的东西背道而驰。然而，他确实尊敬她。他称她为“尼日利亚之母”。
And in 1978, when she died, after the government raided his compound and literally threw her out of a window, he records a song called "Unknown Soldier," where he sings about the incident, and you can hear his voice break.
而在 1978 年，当她去世时，在政府突袭他的院子并字面上把她从窗户扔出去后，他录制了一首叫“不知名士兵”(Unknown Soldier) 的歌，他在歌里唱到这件事，你可以听到他的声音破碎。
Political mama
政治妈妈
Influential mama
有影响力的妈妈
Ideological mama
意识形态妈妈
Them throw my mama out of from window
他们把我的妈妈从窗户扔了出去
Them kill my mama
他们杀了我妈妈
Them carry everybody go
他们带走了所有人
So he never forgot what she'd accomplished, and neither did those market women who marched with her.
所以他从未忘记她的成就，那些与她一起游行的市场妇女也没有。
So let me tell you. My grandmother.
所以让我告诉你。我的祖母。
This is Yeni Kuti, Fela's oldest daughter, Funmilayo Ransome-Kuti's granddaughter.
这位是耶尼·库蒂 (Yeni Kuti)，费拉的长女，富米拉约·兰索姆-库蒂的孙女。
My grandmother, when we were burying her, we went in a convoy to Abeokuta. Abeokuta is her town. When we got to the border of Abeokuta, there was this mammoth crowd of women-- mammoth crowd of women.
我的祖母，当我们埋葬她时，我们组成了车队前往阿贝奥库塔。阿贝奥库塔是她的城镇。当我们到达阿贝奥库塔边界时，那里有成群结队的妇女——成群结队的妇女。
We had to stop. They took her body from us, and they walked with her. And they honored her as the voice of the women. It was a people's funeral. It was a people's funeral.
我们不得不停下来。她们从我们手中带走了她的遗体，她们陪着她走。她们尊称她为妇女的声音。这是一场人民的葬礼。这是一场人民的葬礼。
Jad Abumrad's podcast about Fela is called Fela Kuti: Fear No Man. You can get it wherever you get your podcasts.
贾德·阿布姆拉德关于费拉的播客叫《费拉·库蒂：无惧之人》(Fela Kuti: Fear No Man)。你可以在任何你获取播客的地方收听。
That's my mama who you kill
那就是被你们杀害的我的妈妈
She fought for universal adult suffrage
她为普选权而战
That my mama who you kill
那就是被你们杀害的我的妈妈
She's the only mother of this country
她是这个国家唯一的母亲
That my mama who you kill
那就是被你们杀害的我的妈妈
She's the only mother of Nigeria
她是尼日利亚唯一的母亲
Well, today's program was produced by Valerie Kipnis and Emmanuel Dzotsi. The people who helped put the show together today include Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Sophie Gil, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, and Marisa Robertson-Textor.
好的，今天的节目由瓦莱丽·基普尼斯 (Valerie Kipnis) 和伊曼纽尔·佐齐 (Emmanuel Dzotsi) 制作。今天帮助节目制作的人员包括迈克尔·科米特 (Michael Comite)、苏珊·加伯 (Suzanne Gaber)、苏菲·吉尔 (Sophie Gil)、凯西·霍利 (Cassie Howley)、塞斯·林德 (Seth Lind)、斯托·纳尔逊 (Stowe Nelson)、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多 (Katherine Rae Mondo)、纳迪亚·雷曼 (Nadia Reiman)、阿里莎·希普 (Alissa Shipp)、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉 (Christopher Swetala) 和玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯托 (Marisa Robertson-Textor)。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼 (Sarah Abdurrahman)。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆 (David Kestenbaum)。我们的执行主编是伊曼纽尔·贝里 (Emanuele Berry)。
Jad's collaborators in making his Fela series were Ian Wheeler, Ngofeen Mputubwele, Ruby Harron Walsh, Fayfay Odudu, and Olawakemi Aladesuyi. The series was edited by Ben Adair.
贾德在制作他的费拉系列节目时的合作者有伊恩·惠勒 (Ian Wheeler)、恩戈芬·姆普图布韦莱 (Ngofeen Mputubwele)、鲁比·哈伦·沃尔什 (Ruby Harron Walsh)、法法·奥杜杜 (Fayfay Odudu) 和奥拉瓦凯米·阿拉德苏伊 (Olawakemi Aladesuyi)。该系列由本·阿代尔 (Ben Adair) 编辑。
Special thanks as well to Vtech, Funmi Arewa, Debbie Ohiri, who put together the choir singing protest songs throughout this episode. Adéróké helped translate those songs. The episode was fact checked by Robin Reid and Jamila Wilkinson.
特别感谢 Vtech、Funmi Arewa、Debbie Ohiri，他们组织了合唱团在这一集中演唱抗议歌曲。Adéróké 帮忙翻译了这些歌曲。这一集由罗宾·里德 (Robin Reid) 和贾米拉·威尔金森 (Jamila Wilkinson) 进行了事实核查。
Just a quick reminder that if you like our show and you want us to, you know, keep making it, please become a This American Life partner. You'll get bonus episodes. You'll get ad-free listening. You'll get other perks. But most important, you will join the people who now collectively contribute a fourth of our total budget for our show with their subscriptions, which is amazing.
简单提醒一下，如果你喜欢我们的节目并且希望我们，你知道，继续制作，请成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。你会获得额外剧集。你会获得无广告收听。你会获得其他津贴。但最重要的是，你将加入那些现在集体贡献了我们节目总预算四分之一的捐款者行列，订阅支持，这太棒了。
And when you sign up, you get all kinds of stuff-- bonus episodes, ad-free listening, an archive of greatest hits right in your podcast feed. To join, thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes.
当你注册时，你会获得各种各样的东西——额外剧集、无广告收听、直接在你的播客订阅源中的热门精选档案。要加入，访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。该链接也在节目注释中。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. All his exes live in--
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所 (PRX) 传送给公共广播电台。一如既往，感谢我们项目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚 (Torey Malatia) 先生。他所有的前任都住在——
Taxes.
税收。
Taxes. Taxes. Taxes. Taxes. Taxes.
税收。税收。税收。税收。税收。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。